in esports a split second can change
everything the right play can secure you
tournaments and money or cement your
reputation to put it simply it can
change your life
[Applause]
but in the same way a misplay can ruin
you one wrong click errant skill shot or
misplaced utility can screen disaster
ben is going to cut them off on the back
line god strength and where's the storm
hammer
moments like that can really destroy a
person's psyche at the very highest
level of play one stupid mistake can
haunt you for a long time and due to the
nature of esports sometimes you become
known for your biggest mistakes
so smart he couldn't burst because of
the super
but will she get dicks it's
over oh my god
now if you're lucky you can escape the
life sentence of humiliation not that
your record is ever clean of course the
internet is forever but some people have
been able to take a terrible situation
and turn it to their benefit flipping
one monumental screw-up into a
light-hearted meme instead of letting it
eat you you can own it like i always
like wanted a spot for myself like oh
that summit box right there summer box
now when you die to a molotov by
yourself it's called pulling a summit
it's
kind of like kind of like creating the
name for ourself a little bit
and one man has been able to flip an
awful play into his own personal brand
of self-deprecating humor
ready to take a fight flash over
just cancelled
wait
that was all just canceled
i am of course referring to mark robert
lamont better known as cadrell
professional jungler turned lec caster
by day and sardonic streamer by night a
man whose unique charm and unprecedented
knowledge not only allowed him to
produce one of the most rousing career
stories in recent history but also
turned him into a bit of a streaming
sensation
and i have never known defeat
welcome then [__]
the question is how how has cadrell gone
from a middle of the pack pro with an
unfortunate history to one of the most
recognizable broadcast talents in league
of legends how has he cultivated an
audience who canonizes his words turning
him into one of the fastest growing
streamers on twitch and most importantly
why did he just
cancel i do
i don't even remember whether i'm so
confused why do we have to show that
come on guys
just to recap he flashed over the wall
to all ezreal and then immediately
cancelled his own ultimate by right
clicking
so who is this spectacle don man who
apparently stole his gamertag from a wow
arena teammate well when he's not
live-tweeting about ferrari's f1 woes
you can find him casting in the league
of legends european championship
smurfing in ranked and of course playing
nice with his twist chat
high c drill youth came back from the
dentift and my mouth is feeling numb the
amps like i'm having a lift anyways have
a great dream less than three
shut
up because wasn't always analyzing
league 24 7. instead he was playing as
early as 2015 cadrell was hopping
between different regional eu teams
before finally landing on the uk-based
h2k
now they're looking for a little bit
more cajun gets the presence of mine to
jump on towards brockton and sheriff
gets another fanatic went for the
engagement they fall apart in the hands
of h2k now h2k was a big step for
cadrell's young career and although he
was sharing time let's not discount the
fact that cadrell was playing at
europe's highest level and that comes
with a lot of stress responsibility and
pressure just because you want on the
g2s and fanatics of the world doesn't
mean you aren't under a microscope
fighting for your position and proving
your worth
with enough pressure like that mistakes
are bound to happen and then again with
as much apm as league of legends
misinputs are commonplace the difference
is that when it comes to the best
players on the top teams their blunders
are usually easier to forget or at the
very least forgive but unfortunately for
cadrell his miss play ended up being
pretty memorable one to one in the tower
is a dragon advantage as well
ready to take a fight flash over
just cancelled
wait
that was all just cancelled it yes in
game one of the eu lcs spring split
against vitality cadre found himself in
a very opportune position he flashed
over the raptor wall and had the enemy
ezreal right where he wanted him
unfortunately after casting his malzahar
alt cadrell immediately cancelled it h2k
lost the team fight and eventually they
lost the game
so i flash altered the sril because look
at him he's completely running it okay
and what happens here is i cancel my old
back
now in the grand scheme of things this
loss might not have made a difference
first of all they were already
technically losing the game and even if
they won it's unlikely their seeding
would have changed but the play ended up
affecting cajol in a different and
bigger way it really messed with his
mental you see to make matters worse at
the time he was already dealing with
extremely difficult mental health issues
so although the moment wasn't that big
of a deal to anyone other than him it
just made a bad situation even worse
what i had
personally been dealing with was getting
worse and i wasn't the only thing that i
was like latching on to still was my
confidence in my gameplay
and that was like the only thing that i
had going for me at the time but that
was fading because the stage games i was
playing bad i was really distracted my
mind really wasn't in it so i just got
worse and worse and worse so everything
was kind of falling apart around me
cagel's confidence in his gameplay
something he once trusted started to
decline and seeing players like cap
succeed in the mid lane made cajul doubt
his position in the game so in an effort
to pump some life into his career
cadrell started to experiment in solo
queue and eventually he would end up
swapping roles from mid lane to jungle
so that was the only like positive thing
for me was just like i would queue up
and play jungle and just get distracted
emotionally from everything else
so i said to the coaches i had this
stupidest idea ever
i was like hey let me play jungle in
week four
of the lcs so obviously we went into
that weekend we got absolutely destroyed
and i said you know what i suck at
everything
you guys just kick me or i'll leave
whatever you want we'll just cancel this
contract and i'm out after the swap
cadre hopped from team to team before
getting signed to the org that he would
eventually become synonymous with excel
and he changed something else too kedra
began to pour all of his time into
studying the game trying to understand
it at the most macro level even at the
expense of his own personal play however
not everything went as planned he looked
much more comfortable as a jungler but
he still couldn't help his team get the
results they were looking for and so in
november of 2020 kaidrill made the
decision to retire from competitive play
i tried my hardest to push myself and
the team that i was on
to be as successful as possible but in
the end um we weren't able to achieve
the results
and i can only really um
i can only really blame myself for that
now it was also around this time that
cadre started to lend his expertise to
the broadcast desk at several events
including eu masters and world 2020 and
in that same retirement video cadrell
announced that being on the desk gave
him a new sense of purpose and that he
would be transitioning to a freelance
talent position and with that there was
no shortage of big names giving him a
vote of confidence shortly thereafter
the lec announced cadrell as part of
their on-air talent for the 2021 season
a chance that he did not take for
granted the community sentiment was
really well received in the fact that
they hadn't had a pro player on the desk
for a while since uh division stepped
down
and i could get my quote-unquote pro
player perspective to people who might
not think of the game in certain ways
which gave me a lot of satisfaction to
know that people learned something the
new lec promised professional level
analysis with witty banter and well
that's exactly what the audience got
please start the game
can you please i'm writing right now i
swear
okay he's quite big actually i need to
reposition that's what they all say
about the anchors
so well but that why you shouldn't be
called you should go sam okay so
sam mark and dracos smd
yeah okay yeah that's that's an
abbreviation cagel is in no way the
first pro turn caster but he fits
seamlessly into the lec a broadcast
known for its unique humor and wide
array of content
cadre
hello
you paused during the show how do you
even do that do you know how league of
legends works i mean if you get a bug a
pink spike you just pause the game you
tell the referee something went wrong
and if you ask you're pushing you for
questions or answers you just hold f4
you just disconnect
disconnect from the game like you're
trying to disconnect from this meeting
and disconnect from your
responsibilities
mark
mark an ally is disconnected mark
actually gagel didn't just fit in he
stood out he was an instant fan favorite
and for a multitude of reasons on top of
his charisma and humor cadrell's pro
pedigree really propelled him even to
this day some long-standing casters get
hate from fans who might think they
shouldn't have certain takes if they've
never played the game professionally and
as unfounded as many of these criticisms
may be kegel was different he had a
unique perspective on the game and a lot
of people could trust his opinion due to
his lived experiences even his
contemporaries noticed just how special
he was on the team but cagel is adamant
that he owes everything to them vedius
is extremely extremely talented dracos
as well was pushing me quick shot shocks
as well on the desk like the lac has a
a talent team that if you go into it and
you just accept that you're a sponge and
you're just taking all of these
experienced opinions you know shocks has
been in esports for i don't know how
many years so yeah i'm very very
grateful for the nec and vedios
especially they kind of taught me
everything now during all of this time
through swapping roles and changing
career paths kedra was also working on
something else his stream as early as
january 2017 cagel has been streaming on
twitch but it wasn't until halfway
through 2020 as cadrell was gaining
popularity as a caster that he started
to take his stream more seriously and
almost overnight cadrell jumped from a
few hundred viewers to thousands and
people were tuning into his streams for
the same reason they loved seeing him on
the desk to start he was cracked it's
hard to over stress just how good cadrel
is at this game sure looking back now as
a pro he maybe wasn't the most memorable
but remember this is a guy who played
two different roles at the highest level
of professional play taking that talent
to ranked solo queue he was farming but
he was also losing his mind oh you're
struggled this year as well
oh sure where's your shrekle now
where's your circle jungle card that's
sold as well guard results as well
unfiltered dry humor gave you an
experience you could really only get
from him
huh my second name is robert only one in
this robert in this town [__]
now to save me
every time i boil the eggs they always
come out raw
how long do you boil x4 bruh it's always
raw on the inside
how is how cringe is that seven minutes
he even popularized that's illegal a
term to describe something in league
that is out of left field idiotic or
generally ill-advised the phrase now
lives within the canon of league to the
point where everyone knows what it means
and everyone uses it and maybe best of
all kegel was able to take that once
horrific moment and turn it into a joke
that was no longer at his expense he
made the casting call his sub
notification meaning he literally makes
money whenever he's reminded of that
blunder
fight flash over just cancelled wait
just canceled it cagel finally even got
some extra vindication after a certain
story professional made the same mistake
he did all those years ago
i cancelled it he cancelled it
he did re
as 2021 went on cagel's stream only got
bigger and some of his streams even
reached tens of thousands of viewers by
early 2022 kagel wound up back home
where he was signed as a content creator
for excel since joining excel again
things have been continuing to trend
upwards for cadrell he's now one of the
fastest growing league streamers on the
platform and things don't appear to be
slowing down we can all learn a lot from
cagel's story opportunities come out of
bizarre situations
even what feels like a massive screw-up
can lead to something great and if you
truly love something do whatever you can
to make it a part of your everyday life
if you told me this would be my life two
or three years ago i wouldn't believe
you because
i was
too shy to even step in front of a
camera or take a picture
i was
too reserved to even have a long-form
conversation and i never streamed
i would never expect you to tell me what
i am today so i guess life is full of
surprises huh but the most important
lesson we can learn is to never take
ourselves too seriously we saw the
animation of a tf red card appear in top
lane so i'd love to see the replay of
that cancel caps saves his team on the
top side and the tf ultimate goes on
cooldown you do have a lot of experience
with cancels so we'll see if we can get
it back up for uk draw
we've got a crowd but who's on these now
at least the crowd can express how i
put feel
guides for um things that aren't like
super obvious even though even though i
can take a good guess at this one it's
not like it's not super obvious that
it's you know
i'm like i'm gonna say mark robert
lamont but it could easily be mark
robert
lamore or something right if he's like i
know he's like european so
anyway